what up space fam goals in here from
anime upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest
developments in the one piece story
in this one we get to see the return of
luffy a flying flying six member
and my favorite part the insane reveal
of yamato's devil fruit
so make sure to stay tuned for this one
if you do enjoy these one-piece reviews
and want to keep them coming channel the
pirate king within
and smash that like button until it's
blue if you haven't make this the video
you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell or you will miss future one piece
videos and while you wait for the next
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my growing one piece playlist that
includes videos on all the yonko
supernova admirals and much more link to
that is in the description now without
further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all we
have luffy dominating this week's cover
of sean and jump and he's in a space
uniform which reminds me of the space
uniform senku's dad wore
in dr stone we're also told and i quote
adventuring toward the future end quote
now is this just a fun little crossover
probably
but it makes me think of the theories
that the straw hats will travel to space
so who knows maybe it's a bit of
foreshadowing for what the future of one
piece has in store for us as well
we also get another two page spread this
chapter and both nami
and robin are looking absolutely amazing
i gotta say that
i really gotta get miyanami figure
already but let's jump into the chapter
itself it is called
triceracopter so if you weren't sure
which flying six member will actually
fly
that should give you a better idea we
start with queen versus sanji definitely
a hype matchup queen is fighting with
beams and
sanji is smiling remarking how those
beams would be
great tech for frankie i love how in the
middle of a fight with an all-star
the dude is thinking about how to help
out another member of the nakama and
make him stronger
beautiful stuff we get back to zorro who
is about to get his shot and join the
fight again there's some humor here as
well as miyagi is wondering whether he
should take off the layer of bandages
first and zoro wonders if he even knows
what he's doing the concern is whether
the shot will get through the bandages
and i love how zoro tells him to just
take the bandages off before he gives
him the shot the
dude just wants to get back in action as
soon as possible
we then jump to luffy who's now on law
submarine
they don't know what to do without dr
law and
right now he's unconscious but luckily
luffy wakes up on his
own predictably and hilariously the
first thing he mentions is
meat showing that he is fine and will no
doubt be ready to rumble again sooner
rather than later
now let's turn to frankie versus sasuke
they are both giving each other
compliments for how tough the other is
so big props to frankie for doing this
well against the dude who spoke like one
of the strongest flying six members
sasuke enters his hybrid form and is
holding a sword with mini blades around
the main blade that begin to rotate and
create a sort of drill or helix sword
frankie tells the gifters who switch
sides that he doesn't need help so they
can go help the others
love to see his confidence and
determination when it comes to beating
sasuke and i expect nothing else from
the legend who rode a motorcycle
on a yonko's face god that's still one
of my favorite moments in wano
but then sasuke does something i really
didn't see coming and i don't even know
how it works but it's oda
it's devil fruit powers we know by now
that you just gotta expect the
unexpected with these things
anyways what happens is not only is
sasuke like a dinosaur he's also like a
helicopter
the bony frill around his neck begins to
rotate rapidly
much like his sword and not only could
it probably cut almost
anything it even raises him above the
ground
to frankie's shock and hours it's pretty
hilarious as frankie says wow i didn't
know dinosaurs could do that and
obviously triceratops couldn't
but oda is being creative and having
some fun with sasuke here
sasuke's sasuki's ex-underlings have
clearly seen this and know how bad it is
so they warned frankie their iron bro to
run and it's classic one piece where
it's supposed to be such a
seriously dangerous ability and yet i
can't stop laughing at how funny it
looks in action
sasuke unleashes his titular move
triceracopter
and this bizarre move does serious
damage clearly hurting a lot of the
gifters present
i love to see frankie so concerned about
them after they just joined his side
recently but yeah the triceracopter
is no joke people saseki attacks frankie
who manages to hold him off with his
sword at first he remarks that he didn't
expect this to turn into an aerial
battle
and we're right there with you frankie
we're told that the triceratops is a
pretty special breed of dinosaur and yes
this one definitely is and frankie
notices that the weird propellers are
boosting his speed
a lot we get a very interesting standoff
where first sasaki uses his propellers
to send himself backwards
a bit to give him a bigger runway for a
propeller enhanced charge
in the meantime frankie prepares his
shield by the way i love how at first
when sasuke went backwards frankie
straight up thought the dinocopter
made a mistake and is shocked that it
was all part of the plan
with the extra momentum sasuke propels
himself into frankie using the move
try sarah bullet and it causes frankie's
shoulder launcher to misfire
however frankie being the legend he is
turns this defensive position
into an attack and uses general suplex
to slam sasuke into the ground
although frankie pinpoints sasuke's
belly as his weak spot
susaki does manage to escape before
frankie can land a significant hit
susaki gains the upper hand as his sword
slices through frankie's and frankie
starts to run
shocked by the fact that his franken
sword was shattered frankie decides to
meet tricera bullet
with a move called gaeon cannon encore
general cannon
and he actually sends sasuke flying back
in the
air it's a great panel showing just how
much air time this flying sex member is
getting now
you could tell by his expression and the
blood that this one definitely hurt
sasuke he bounces back though telling
frankie not to underestimate the flying
six members who everyone fears he
launches an attack but
again frankie manages to get the upper
hand in a very creative way this time i
must say
he ejects himself from the giant body
and hits sasaki with a surprise radical
beam
right in the belly which is supposed to
be his weakest spot
again a white eyed sasuke hits the
ground and this fight may well be over
as far as we can see
i think they definitely did give it
ample time and susaki got to show off
all of his abilities
even abilities we never ever dreamed of
so i would be cool with this being the
end of this one and props to frankie for
absolutely killing it here i'm just
gonna say right now rather than at the
end
my boy frankie is mvp for this chapter
whatever happens even if sasuke gets up
this was amazing the dude took down a
triceracopter
after all what more can you ask of a bro
then we jump to yamato
and kaido still fighting and arguing
kaido wants yamato on his side so
bad to bring up the beast pirates
military strength
and i truly believe there's something
there about wanting his child
specifically to be by his side too
aside from just military power but
obviously kaido is not the type who
would easily admit that in his own
messed up way i do think he values the
father
child relationship that he has with
yamato but there's also the practical
value of the devil fruta yamato eight
and here we get to the good stuff we're
told that kaido went through a lot to
get that devil fruit ayanko going
through a lot to get a devil fruit is
always a big deal we know blackbeard
went through a lot to get the dark dark
fruit and
shank seemingly went through a lot to
get the gomu gomu no me
so this is a hype fruit no doubt about
that yamato
didn't eat it on purpose but
accidentally because of hunger either
way it gave yamato the power to fight
kaido which is no small feat
obviously yamato loses every time but
also becomes stronger after every battle
and again it's telling how many times
they battled and kaido never thought to
kill his child even when yamato was
trying to kill him
i mean now we could argue it's because
of how special the fruit is
but we shall see we also found out that
yamato stayed
not just because of the shackles but
because odin would never abandon this
country which makes a lot of sense
we get a full page showing off this epic
devil fruit form and
it not gonna lie sort of looks like a
deer but of course a deer zone fruit
wouldn't really justify the way kaido is
talking about it
my favorite theory that i've heard so
far is that it's a kirin a creature from
japanese folklore which would be perfect
since we are in wana right now after all
this would make yamato's fruit a
mythical zone
which would make a lot more sense
because of how kaido is talking about it
but let's take a look at some of the
unique features of the kirin and this
info i'm about to mention comes from the
yokai wiki page
about the kirin if you're curious about
learning more so it's considered one of
the rarest and most
powerful creatures ever known in east
asia definitely a reason for a yonko to
want its powers
it is considered to be regal and godly
it is a chimerical beast resembling a
deer
with scales like a dragons covering its
body kirin are said to appear as heralds
of a golden age which goes along with a
lot of the prophecy stuff in one piece
they don't harm the good and pure which
is why it makes sense for yamato to be
on luffy's side rather than kaidos we
should look out for some fire attacks
too because kirin are known to breathe
holy fire from their mouths
the flowing mane like hair and tail
definitely look like yamato could be
akiren as well they are associated with
virtue and justice traits that
definitely fit yamato and her obsession
over odin
furthermore and this is a huge detail
they're associated with luck and fortune
and are believed to be a sign of the
arrival of a great leader if this isn't
a perfect fit for the story where luffy
is obviously a great rising leader
and where he'll need luck and fortune on
his side to beat kaido
then i don't know what is and finally as
if this power needed more hyping up
the kirin is said to be the most
powerful and sacred beast of all
surpassing the ho'o in power all of us
pokemon fans should know that that's a
huge deal so yeah i think that would be
a perfect fit and it makes a lot of
sense to me
obviously the story version won't
reflect the myth exactly since oda is
the guy who turns dinosaurs into
helicopters
so you gotta give him some room for
creative license but i would love this
theory to pan out
and then imagine luffy gets this
mythical zone user to join his crew oh
my god that would be so hype
in short solid chapter we got to see a
helicopter dinosaur
frankie won the mvp award for me let me
know if you would give it to anyone else
and we got to see a beautiful devil
fruit transformation from yamato
who might just have the most mythical of
mythical zone fruits
but that is it for this chapter as
always thank you so much for watching if
you do enjoy these one piece reviews and
want to keep them coming channel the
pirate king within
and smash that like button until it's
blue if you haven't make this the video
subscribe and hit that notification bell
or you will miss future one piece
chapter reviews and videos and while you
wait for the next chapter to drop feel
free to check out my growing
one piece playlist that includes videos
on the yonko supernova admirals and much
more link to that
is in the description and i especially
want to thank the patron squad over on
patreon and here on youtube who helped
make videos like this one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord wigo himself alpha sigma
and are the one tier patrons the ones
who stand atop all clans
in grata but they have the al-jatal
hinokami and water the toasted she the
spike eight two two seven
emperor otaku spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist cody hebert and
monkey d
quilly and our pro hero tier patrons the
one and only gilgamesh the red haired
raven
angel crews rathu and deiora alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia ted no
ted fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul
rise slice and dice thank you all so
much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar or you can
become a channel member here on youtube
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these amazing people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life and of course thank memes so
check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested and as i mentioned you
can also join the youtube channel by
clicking that blue join button next to
the subscribe button that you've
hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way to
support us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you